The jogan
Experience Mexico Calona cartels message
to members stop making fenel or die good
wow crime group yields to intensifying
US law enforcement pressure and is
kidnapping or killing producers who defy
its ban on trafficking the opioid good
interesting good I'm with them I wonder
why well I mean it's [__] up their
business their business is selling
cocaine and then these guys make fenyl
and they cut the cocaine with fenyl and
people are dying
and then law enforcement pressure starts
ramping up and then what they're really
worried about is an invasion the
military decides to go after the cartel
the cels are [__] right I mean they
start air striking cartels with
jets yeah that's a wrap yeah crazy how
crazy is that how the how like the fenel
these days is mixed with Tran or it's
Tran have you heard of that what's
Tran I can't believe you haven't heard
of this Tran with a Q so Tran is
fentanyl mixed with a horse horse
tranquilizer
so the horse tranquilizer makes the
fentanyl last much longer is my
understanding Jamie's probably looking
it up right now but the the Tran is a
horse tranquilizer they mix it with
fentol I think to make it last longer
and make it more powerful and the [__]
up thing is it's so toxic they they all
inject it it's so toxic that it it uh
it's so poisonous in your body that your
that that your body's trying to get rid
of it so it creates these massive sorce
where the the drug is trying to get out
I saw that in Russia yeah and people no
it's here now dude big time is people
are getting sepsis and having to get
their their their limbs amputated it's
really really Nar go back to that
article that you were just posting da
like message about XY xylazine is making
the deadliest drug threat in our country
that our country has ever faced fenel
even deadlier said administrator milram
milram uh DEA sees xylazine and fenal
mixtures in 48 of 50 states the DEA
laboratory system is reporting that in
2022 apparently approximately rather 23%
of fenel powder and 7% of fenel pills
seized by the DEA contains
xylazine [__] yeah I have a weird um I
don't know if obsession is the right
word but I like watching like drug
documentaries and like interviews with
like drug addicts and like you know uh
DEA agents like all that kind of stuff
is just kind of fascinating to me
because I don't have a drug problem and
it's just interesting to me how people
like well choose to go down that road
over and over and over even though it
just seems like the worst thing ever but
I the the like the addicts when they
talk about being on fentanyl they'll
choose the xylazine now with the
fentanyl because it's much
better and they know they're going to
die from it like really soon and they
keep choosing it it's pretty wild and if
you're a heroin addict you can't even
find heroin these days you can't get
heroin all fenel really yeah I've had a
few different friends die from fantinel
um they thought they were buying a like
a baggie of cocaine and a partying yeah
and just Dro dead yeah that that
happened to a group of comedians in La
recently it's so messed up [__]
horrible and the it's the number one
killer I think of of people in like 18
to 49 something nuts like that it's like
100,000 people a year dying of
overdoses what do you think about
parents sending test kits with their
with kids to go to parties so they can
test the drugs well it's certainly
better than not testing it and taking it
obviously the best thing would be to
don't take any drugs but you know
especially when kids are drinking you're
you're [__] all your judgment goes
out the window you're not thinking
straight you're drunk and then someone
offers Coke and there's peer pressure
and you're like I'll try it and then
next thing you go you're dead you know
it if if there was a method of testing
and I know they use that a lot at Raves
because that was one of the issues at
Raves was that people were buying MDMA
and that was laced with fence and wind
up overdosing with that yeah that's
[__] scary [__] man also uh parents
are sending their kids naron or Naran
Naran to to help them survive and
overdose well and to help other people
yeah um I heard a lot of kids in
Portland are being trained and sending
their kids to school with Narcan and
they're trained to give Narcan to heroin
addicts or to pel addicts um which is
crazy that's the other thing they say in
those documentaries they they always
interview the addicts and they say how
many times have you over or they say
have you ODed before and they're all
like yeah of course and they're how many
times and they all say countless they
don't know imagine oding so many times
where you literally do not know how many
times it's been and then going straight
back and getting high again like with a
needle yeah it's nuts it's a it's a real
crisis yeah it really is a crisis I I
mean you have have kids I have kids so
these are things that are like totally
on the front burner for me like to me
I'm never sending my kids to a party
with with uh test kits that's not like
that's I feel like talking to them from
a super young
age totally having super transparent
heart-to-heart talks with them about
friends that I've had that thought they
were getting one drug and it was laced
with this [__] that is completely deadly
and dropping dead just drugs are
different man they're not how it was
when we were kids when we were kids like
people would experiment it was
completely normal like I feel like those
days are over in some some aspects you
know for sure well the real problem and
this is a very uncomfortable discussion
but the real problem is that drug
prohibition has made criminals the only
source of drugs and you have no idea
what you're getting and that's the
problem and if you make drugs legal all
drugs
legal you're going to have a bunch of
people that are doing drugs that
wouldn't do drugs if they were illegal
so you have that problem and so how do
you mitigate that how long does it take
for the dust settles and life normalizes
because if you think about the
prohibition in the United States
prohibition of alcohol in the United
States propped up the mob everybody
knows that it's a fact it's widely
openly discussed the only people that
were selling the alcohol were the people
that were criminals they made a shitload
of money they they amassed massive power
because of that and they they you know
they used it they used it to control
cities they and and until they got
infiltrated and the mob got broken up
they they they for a long time they
reaped the rewards of the power that
they started to develop during
prohibition and that's exactly what
you're seeing with the cartels the
reason why the cartels have so much
power is because there's so much demand
for illegal drugs in the United States
and that's not going away well it's not
going away no people have always wanted
to do drugs there's always going to be a
certain lost segment of our population
that wants Escape reality with some
[__] hardcore [__] that puts them in
a trance yeah well they're finding it
yeah if they want that it's everywhere
what is Hawaii's problems what is like
uh like on the big island what are their
main uh drug problems I mean it's been
meth for the most part for like the last
20 years that's taken a toll there's no
doubt about it meth meth has been like
probably the biggest problem but now
it's turning into
fenel now it's turning into fenel one of
one of the little girls in my daughter's
circle of friends was on Instagram live
this is like two years ago a girl was
like 12 years old she was like on
Instagram live no one was home at her
house and she went in her mom's medicine
cabinet and she found a little baggie of
white powder oh God and chopped it up on
in a line uh on Instagram live she just
had her friends or whatever like her 10
15 friends that follow her like a little
girl and was like J me and she snorted
it it was pure fenel oh God and it turns
out her mom was selling it that I was on
the big island in my my daughter's
little circle of
friends and she died that's happening
everywhere man that's my little tiny
town that I feel is like a little town
like a little farm town that grows
coffee and like that's where you surf
and hang out it's like super mellow but
somehow that's really happening like
it's it's that th those drugs have
infiltrated like every last
little corner of our country it's wild
man wild it is wild and the alternative
doesn't seem repealing either the
alternative of making heroin and cocaine
legal at stores that scares the [__] out
of me too yeah it's weird that it's like
it's like Regional like like it's really
bad in Canada horrible the drug like
drug epidemic like I was in
um not Toronto what's the other giant
City in the west coast Vancouver
Vancouver holy crap yeah thousands and
thousands and thousands of homeless
people homeless uh fenel zombies all
over these like big city blocks like
thousands of them like you know slumped
over have you seen that the when they
get slumped over that's the Tran so
that's a tranquilizer thing so they it's
super high and they're tranquilizer so
they basically are like like you know
they don't they don't fall but they like
swing but I feel like in in Canada it's
huge in the US it's huge but I just was
I was in France and Spain none of that